is a little weird that we split people
by male and female in this way College
wrestler listen to me but the average
woman is not going to be able to take
the average woman wrestler is not going
to be able to take down you when you
were in your your people okay maybe like
this female
yeah it's like I see only women and men
it's crazy it's like sex really is
binaries no question about it you're
either male or female pushing that
agenda onto kids and confusing people in
gaslighting that hey XX who knows maybe
XY who knows when you start talking like
that with facts
and you're a respectable scientist not
only do you sound delusional but what
you sound like is someone like Leon
black that somebody has something behind
closed doors on you that's blackmailing
you that you have to now agree with
these positions for somebody to say how
the hell did you go from being a
respected scientist to all of a sudden
saying one day I can wake up feeling
like a female one day I can wake up
feeling like a male and why do you care
for those that don't know Neil deGrasse
Tyson is an American astrophysicist
author and science Communicator Tyson he
studied at Harvard University the
University of Texas so he's pretty much
a man of science and he was one of those
who was saying follow the science and
now he has this to say I'm gonna get you
a reaction point is apparently the xxxy
chromosomes are insufficient
because when we wake up in the morning
we exaggerate whatever feature we want
to portray the gender of our choice
either the one you're assigned the one
you choose to be whatever it is and so
now here so so now just to tie a bow on
this I say to you
somewhere I read
somewhere I think I read that the United
States was a land where we have the
pursuit of happiness
suppose no matter my chromosomes today I
feel 80 percent female 20 male I'm gonna
I'm gonna put on makeup I'm gonna do
this tomorrow I might feel 80 male I'll
remove the makeup and I'll wear a muscle
shirt
why do you care yeah what what what
business it is it of yours
to require that I fulfill
your inability to think of gender on a
spectrum is uh is that other brother
with you what's his name yeah yeah he's
here zisha where is he at
where's my brother zeeshan he's here the
man with the plant if he can't nobody
can how you doing brother
bro how are you okay yeah how you doing
I heard you in the background how you
been yeah
bro yeah just uh just trolling the dean
show you know uh trying to get famous
so have you guys both heard of this uh
Neil uh the grass Tyson I watched it
yesterday I'm absolutely that's why when
I was watching it um I was a bit
confused because I went to zishan I said
is he Pro or against because the video
it seems like he's against at the
beginning so I'm confused I'm like is he
against or is he Pro I don't I'm still
confident he said to me no it's actually
Pro lgbqt which is pretty amazing
because he's supposed to be a scientist
he's supposed to be academically
intellectually honest a lot of people
when they're atheist they they say look
when it comes to science it's objective
and you know we can take it and you know
we rely on it over God and over
testimony so hey you've got a scientist
now that's using the same framework and
he's arriving at the conclusion that you
can wake up and you can be a man the
next day you can wake up as a female so
it'll be interesting to see what these
atheists have to say frankly sex really
is binary there's no question about it
you're either male or female and it's
absolutely clear you can do it on gamete
sides you can do it on chromosomes to me
as a biologist distinctly weird people
can simply declare I am a woman though I
have a penis it seems like now this is
this is anti-guard obviously
anti-science I just teach basic biology
that's all I teach let's talk about one
particular day when you're in the middle
of your lecture and you kind of notice
that four students have gotten up and
walked out of your classroom what were
you teaching that day that appeared to
trigger them to cause them to exit the
room that day I was teaching the chapter
on human reproductive system
so in when I teach human reproductive
system you know I emphasize on the fact
that male and female uh or the maleness
or the female illness are controlled by
two genes see in our all our cells we
have 23 pairs of genes and uh sorry
chromosomes chromosomes so the 20 third
pair is that determines the sex of a
person
so if that 23rd a pair of chromosomes
are x and x it is a female and if it's X
and Y it's a male
and I mentioned in the class that that's
what makes male and female not our
thinking it's a satanic rhetoric and
there's a great statement that the only
necessary thing for the Triumph of evil
is for good men to do nothing so we're
trying to do something to combat this
and obviously this is coming from people
who you would think you know would come
out and speak up but against this
because they're scientists but they're
actually speaking speaking uh towards
this uh this whole uh what do you want
to call it I mean this is this madness
you know you know the most um it's
hopefully it won't be a shock to most
people but the way things are at the
moment the LGBT are heavily uh
especially the LGBT Lobby is heavily
funding two aspects in particular and um
one is of course education that's why
they're on the board of a lot of these
uh
um universities especially in the US and
then they're funding the what is it the
medical industrial complex which which
some argue is actually more prominent
than the military industrial complex
because that's where most of it's going
to happen so there's a lot of big bucks
to be had
um from of course peddling this LGBT
thing and they've definitely got their
kind of eggs in the in the right basket
and they're leveraging people like this
frankly you can't necessarily be an
academic who wants tenure who wants
credibility who now will openly go
against LGBT T I mean that's what we're
seeing with with needle to Grass Tyson
we're gonna see he's going to be one of
many and uh no no one can kind of make
this claim I don't think so that science
is is objective and you know we can use
it to determine X and Y which I don't
think anybody in their right mind does
Ali would you agree when I say X and Y
they're talking about X and Y chromosome
come on G okay
what's the situation there in London
where you guys are are there's a big
Muslim Community there is there a good
pushback against a lot of this in the
schools because primarily you know this
is what's Happening Here is probably
happening over there they're pushing
this this sexualization of the children
in the schools so that they're they're
having this pretty much pornographic
content for four five six-year-olds
they're showing and and then when uh for
instance you have a someone who stands
up and shows this stuff and starts
reading from these books at a board
meeting even the board members are like
hey slow it down do we you know what are
you doing and then the person is like
hold on you can't even let hear me
reading this but you want to show this
to the children or they'll actually blur
it out on the news but they want to show
this to the kids
what's going on over there in your part
of the world with this I mean over here
yes I mean it's unexposed well you can't
say it's unexpected but the only kind of
religious group that's actually coming
to the to the front are Muslims and um
you'll see even the people that are
anti-islam like the the far right and
the the right wing even they are
appreciating the fact that we're coming
forward but the problem is that because
we're the ones with the loudest voice it
gets turned into a religious thing and
unfortunately
um not much gets done I mean we saw it
in Birmingham as well remember
um when you know Muslim parents said
they they had enough I we even saw in
Canada as well and there was a Canadian
Pastor that came forward we put on s2j
news.com that he came forward and he
said you know what thanks to the Muslim
Community but the thing is that I mean
Muslim Community comes with a sort of
kind of stereotype and a propaganda and
the media loves to kind of bash us so
for for I for it to be more effective
active we're gonna need the Orthodox
Jewish and Orthodox or just the
Christians in general to come forward as
well it's going to have to be a team
effort but I don't know if that that's
going to be happening but rest assured
the Muslims will will not take this
lying down frankly and that's what we're
seeing over here there is uh constant
challenges by parents there is a
pushback but unfortunately and sadly
where we're seeing UK I mean tag along
with what's going on in the US as well
what do you think all right thank you
for the input on that guys
alhamdulillah brothers and sisters as
you can see we've acquired the property
and we're getting right to work and with
your duas and support we can go ahead
and get the Masjid and meghadawa Center
up open and running in sha Allah imagine
every person that prays here gets
educated and guided to Islam here you'll
get a part of all those blessings and
rewards insha Allah what are you waiting
for brothers and sisters you're going to
leave it all behind anyway so go ahead
and invest in your Hereafter that's
Everlasting click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
foreign
[Music]